Some people ask the question of what
good is math?
What is the relationship between math
and physics?
Well,
sometimes math leads,
sometimes physics leads.
Sometimes they come together because of
course there's a use for the
mathematics.
For example,
in the 16 hundreds,
Isaac Newton ask a simple question.
If an apple falls,
then does the moon also fall?
That is perhaps one of the greatest
questions ever asked by a member of
homosapiens since the 6 million years
since we parted ways with the apes.
If an apple falls,
does the moon also fall?
Isaac Newton said yes,
the moon falls because of the inverse
square law sodas an apple.
He had a unified theory of the heavens,
but he didn't have the mathematics to
solve the falling moon problem.
So what did he do?
He invented calculus.
So Calculus is a direct consequence of
solving the falling moon problem.
In fact,
when you learn calculus for the first
time,
what is the first thing you do it?
What's the first thing you do with
calculus?
You calculate the motion of falling
bodies,
which is exactly how Newton calculated
the falling moon,
which opened up celestial mechanics.
So here's a situation where math and
physics were almost co-joined,
like,
like Siamese twins born together for a
very practical question,
how do you calculate the motion of
celestial bodies?
Then here comes Einstein asking a
different question and that is what is
the nature and origin of gravity?
Einstein said that gravity is nothing
but the byproduct of curves space.
So why am I sitting in this chair?
A normal person would say,
I'm sitting in this chair because
gravity pulls me to the ground.
But Einstein said,
no,
no.
There's no such thing as gravitational
pull.
The earth has curved this space over my
head and around my body.
So space is pushing me into my chair.
So to summarize Einstein's theory,
gravity does not pull space pushes,
but you see the pushing of the fabric of
space and time requires differential
calculus.
That is the language of curved surfaces,
differential calculus which you learned
in fourth year of Calculus.
So again,
here's a situation where math and
physics were very closely combined,
but this time math came first.
The theory of curved surfaces came
first.
Einstein took that theory of curved
surfaces and then imported it into into
a physics.
Now we have string theory.
It turns out that 100 years ago,
math and physics parted ways.
In fact,
when Einstein proposed special
relativity in 19 Oh,
five,
that was also around the time of the
birth of topology,
the typology of hyper dimensional
objects,
spheres in 10,
11,
12,
26,
whatever dimension you want.
So physics and mathematics parted ways.
Math went into hyperspace and
mathematicians said to themselves,
ah Ha.
Finally we have found an area of
mathematics that has no physical
application whatsoever.
Mathematicians pride themselves as being
useless.
They love being useless.
It's a.
it's a badge of courage being useless,
and they said the most useless thing of
all is a theory of differential topology
and higher dimensions.
Well,
physics plotted along for many decades.
We worked out atomic bombs.
We worked out stars,
we worked out laser beams,
but recently we discovered string theory
and string theory exists in 10 and 11
dimensional hyperspace.
Not only that,
but these dimensions are super.
They're super symmetric,
a new kind of numbers that mathematician
has never talked about.
Evolve within string theory,
that's what we call it,
super string theory.
While the mathematicians were floored,
they were shocked because all of a
sudden out of physics came new
mathematics,
super numbers,
super topology,
super tiff,
differential geometry.
All of a sudden we had supersymmetric
theories coming out of physics that then
revolutionized mathematics,
and so the goal of physics we believe is
to find an equation,
perhaps no more than one inch long,
which will allow us to unify all the
forces of nature and allow us to read
the mind of God and what is the key to
that one?
Didn't you?
Equation Super Cemetery,
a cemetery that comes out of physics,
not mathematics and has shocked the
world of mathematics,
but you see all this as pure mathematics
and so the final resolution could be
that God is a mathematician,
and when you read the mind of God,
we actually have a candidate for the
mind of God.
The mind of God,
we believe is cosmic music,
the music of strings resonating through
11 dimensional hyperspace.
That is the mind of God.